oddio oddio benvenuti giovani testa ed
oggi video slime speciale perché andrò a
fare il tipo di sel che non ho mai fatto
un esperimento che non ho mai provato
che sempre voluto provare andrò a fare
lo slam con le pipe bomb proverò in due
modi così vediamo come se in un modo
come ce n'è un altro speriamo che esca
il top o due bust bond ma questa che è
fighissima perché tre colori e poi in
questa la coda da sirena bellissima
allora andrò parlato finiture modi e se
volete vedere altri esperimenti slyvco
altri video club drammi lascia più belle
laiche 10.000 l'ice andrò a farmi un
altro e lasciate pure le vostre idee nei
commenti
e ora siete pronti iniziamo subito ok
allora quello che faccio innanzitutto è
aprire la bat bomb questa prima bat bomb
andrò a scioglierla nell'acqua
direttamente e in verità non ho messo
moltissima acqua
ma vediamo se c'è bisogno di aggiungerla
per farla sciogliere tutto ok ragazzi
siete pronti immergiamo la bac bol
[Musica]
mou che figo guardate che so di che
colore è su cui rilassante questo sono
il proprio sms
fatemi sapere se anche voi si rilassa
che allora in realtà volevo aggiungere
la colla dopo che finiva di freddare ma
sto pensando cosa succede se aggiungo la
colla ad es troviamo speriamo che non
esplosa i dicasteri 3 speriamo che non
rispondiamo alla colla trasparente addio
oggi sta crescendo con rate ma cosa sta
crescendo
spero che non tra bordi che strano o sta
facendo tutte le borse dell'alcol
portate
benissimo io sembra che abbia
solidificato la colla ciò che sta
succedendo
sentiremo con la spatola questa notte
sta solidificando la cosa senza neanche
che ci stia attivatore addio fra i più
troppo strano sta solidificando
d'accordo ma compatibile proprio da
aggiungere al tracolla paura che
strabordi tu
nel frattempo sta continuando a
frizzanti e troppo stretta nei questa
come cordate sta formando lo slang da
solo e super strano anzi continua a
freddare cioè guardate è troppo entro la
qual cosa si è formato una sorta di
slime sopra oh mio dio
ora la parte tutta perde gialla vedete
si è sorto già quella rosa o con le
casse c'è c'è praticamente certo
disclaimer sottospecie di plant o pro ma
io non ho neanche messo un attimo attore
denso come carlo ha fatto a formare non
va bene troppo strade sta cosa provo ad
aggiungere della colla bianca vede un
comizio addio addio corrette sta facendo
strabone
guardate se te le buone della con
io penso che questa cosa esplodere per
non mero oh mio dio
nuovo attacco su sta succedendo
oddio tube regola base bomber sta
continuando nel frattempo proprio mentre
ancora colla
oddio oddio guardate sempre troppo urban
frattempo si è solidificata anche la
colla bianche come possibile o perduti
non ci posso credere che si è formato lo
slide così dal niente perché come
schifato da cole che strano come ho
fatto a formarsi senza siluppo rico sono
con le bollicine
ok fatto a tirarlo fuori
nel frattempo che questo continua a
frizzare all'infinito la tirò fuori qua
e vedo esattamente cos'è questa cosa
perché com'è possibile
guardate com'è possibile che si è
solidificata così la colla ho messo la
soluzione per lenti che in effetti lo
stop lo stai indurendo ancora di più
però guardate contro estraneo che fa
consistenza o mio dio e lo slam più
assurdo che abbia mai fatto penso e
ragazze in questo era l'esperimento
numero uno qual è uscito uno slam
non lo so super super strano e qua sta
continuando ad andare questo club
continuano a forma
tra i pezzi di drive obiettivo che cos'è
il proposta cosa comunque il primo
purtroppo non è uscito meno che non vi
piace questo tipo di slime stranissimo e
ora passiamo nel secondo esperimento ok
ragazzi secondo esperimento allora penso
e con riferimento vado a mettere della
colla trasparente troppo finizio
accettava con la trasparente quindi vado
ad aggiungere questa della helms che
comunque trasparente però all'inter
dentro che comunque benissimo che per
l'effetto rosa
aggiungo anche un po di viola vediamo
come diventa wow il colore mi piacciono
tantissimo su bellissime parate belli ma
ora esempio la sun bellissimi con dei
bellissimi click
ok ora vado ad atti farlo ancora
mi piace tantissimo
[Applauso]
ragazze e bellissimo mi piace tantissimo
quasi vorrei tenerlo così ma dobbiamo
ancora fare un esperimento numero 2 e
cioè aggiungere la bat bombe in questo
caso a lo slime formato speriamo bene
speriamo che esca bene perché questo
slam è veramente bellissimo e non si è
schiarito ancora il piano di bolle
quindi chissà come sarà con si sarà
chiarito completamente ragazzi ecco qua
fatto ad immergere questa batte bomb
coda di sirena dentro lo slime datemi
nome a questo slime qualcosa a che fare
con serena sicuramente ora la immergo e
periodo questa succede comunque è
davvero bellissimo
wow allora guardate ha lasciato il segno
lasciato anche la polverina c'è è
fighissimo hanno proprio made immergerlo
un po'di ricopriamo la con lustrale
allora avrei dovuto fare un po più di
slime ma appunto purtroppo proprio oggi
ho finito la colla si sta attrezzando
non so come si dice si sta sciogliendo
tipo io ho portate si sta sciogliendo
piano piano sentite soli che figo addio
poiché non rimane stranissimo attacca di
sony
guardate quella che sta diventando un
mix con il blu
guardate non l'ho ancora sciolto sotto
finora è diventato un mix con il blu
fichissimo tipo dei pezzetti di bath mob
dentro palette che ricopriamo l'ancora
guardate sta creando le bolle sopra
spero che non succeda come l'altra che
lo sciolga sotto penate le polle booker
t go cioè guardate sembra tipo un
vulcano è stranissimo continua a fritta
trend sacco guardate qua come sta
diventando la coda e mezzo rosa o addio
sta trasformando un sacco la sla
incollati che strano ma anche la cosa
sta cambiando è diventata tipo mezzo
rosa wow
continuiamo a farlo sciogliere
cioè guardarsi alle bolle sopra sembra
che lo stia cuoccio l'importante è
stranissimo preso vita
ok ragazzi è passata tipo mezz'ora
guardate con la coda che fossilizzata
tipo dentro ma non si è ancora sciolta
del tutto togliamo la cui vediamo un po
oddio grate è diventata celeste ma non
si è sciolta invece lo slime se a parte
che è diventato blu
poi si è un pò indurito in sa e si è
riempito un po datati o con la
consistenza e stranissima però allora la
consistenza e un po brutta adesso però
devo dire che il colore fico sembrati
punti allo stellato addio che strano per
cambiata completamente con
si è indurito un bel po
e anche questo si è riempito un po
d'acqua sembra tipo uno squeeze i ball
pieno d'acqua ma già che ci stiamo
vediamo un po come si scioglie questo
appalto bob visto che non si è sciolta
del tutto facciamola strano perché non
pu frizza forse difettosa questa pop bat
bomb portata non ha più niente non si
scioglie più
provo a romperla a chi è troppo dura
no no non ce la faccia niente
insomma la bat bomba rimasta intatta ma
lo slime no
fatemi sapere nei commenti se volete
vedere altri esperimenti slime
scrivetemi tutti gli esperimenti che
volete che provi a fare con gli slide o
con altre cose è lasciato in bella è che
questo video e se volete appunto vederne
altri ottimi sapere cosa ne pensate che
questi esperimenti purtroppo sono stati
un po fail
ma almeno abbiamo visto quanto uscirà
questo ha battuto
ora vi lascio al 4 caselline su cui
potete cliccare per vedere nei prossimi
video cliccate pure su quella che
preferite e buona visione